was ist da oben
hier zum Beispiel die Dusche ist
ziemlich kaputt wie schön wäre das wir
kommen meine ganzen Einkochgläser hin
ich habe mir das unser Gartenschuppen
und Hühnerstall also falls wir noch zehn
Kinder kriegen da ist noch Platz in der
Schule
[Musik]
willkommen zu unserer Hochtour wir haben
diesen Resthof gekauft und ich zeige
euch jetzt mal wie hier alles aussieht
fangen wir da an das ist nämlich richtig
cool
wir haben richtig tolle klingelt
aber das ist unpraktisch dass wir so
eine Glastür haben weil ich war schon
einmal nackig als der Postbote
geklingelt hat und da musste ich mich da
hinten in der Küche verstecken deswegen
muss sie ein Vorhang nehmen oder andere
Tür das ist das Wohnzimmer hier werden
wir ab heute Abend oder morgen erstmal
den Boden abschleifen weil hier stand
früher in den Kamin deswegen ist der
Boden da noch so ein bisschen verfärbt
der geht in die Küche wir haben eine
ganz tolle Vorratskammer mit einer Tür
die noch nicht funktioniert aber kriegen
wir noch hin der beste Ort im ganzen
Haus meine ganzen Einkochgläser hin ich
habe meine letzte Vorratskammer auch
schon versucht schön einzurichten das
will ich ja auch wieder machen ich liebe
auch diese ganzen kleinen Details die
die vorherigen Besitzer hier haben zum
Beispiel ist das hier so ein Stopper für
die Tür die einfach selber geschnitzt
haben und hier haben wir eine große
küchenhexe funktioniert auch und hier
ist die Küche das haben die bisherigen
Besitzer selber gebaut ich finde die
auch sehr schön aber ich glaube mein
Freund und ich sind zu unordentlich für
offene Schränke eine Sache die ein
bisschen doof ist aber vor allem sehr
cool ist dieser Keller hier das Problem
ist dass die Küche bei hier die Falltür
ist so 30 cm tief ist an der ganzen
langen Seite und das finde ich doof
deswegen überlege ich ob wir die
Vorratskammer woanders hin bauen
vielleicht hier drüber und die Küche
darüber packen aber auf jeden Fall
wollen wir diese Türchen nicht zu bauen
weil das ist richtig cool das ist ganz
cool hier unten
hier kann man noch viel mehr einkaufen
Kartoffeln und Fermente daran und
sozusagen super cool
ja das ist ganz praktisch oder da muss
man nicht immer ganz runterlaufen
noch ein kleiner Teil der Küche das war
ja alles schon drin hier war bisher das
Esszimmer und hier sind auch so lauter
Fenster zum Flur hinten das ist ein
Fachwerkhaus von
1850 ungefähr das ist eigentlich ja
ziemlich gut erhalten wir müssen nur die
Dämmung noch verbessern
hier ist das Arbeitszimmer von meinem
Freund das hat ein richtig tollen äh
quarkboden dann hat er immer schön warme
Füße ja wir müssen noch viel an den
Wänden machen hier war anscheinend ein
großes Regal da müssen wir noch ganz
viel spachteln und streichen mein Freund
hat sehr interess Sachen in seinem Büro
stehen
kein Kommentar
ja hier mit diesem Flur da würde ich
sehr gerne den Boden neu machen aber
eines nach dem anderen was trinken wir
als ist dieses Bad hier zum Beispiel die
Dusche ist ziemlich kaputt
richtig runter gerockt und auch einfach
nicht so schön und wenn der mal
irgendwann Zeit und Geld haben dann für
das Einsteigen Projekt wahrscheinlich
oder
okay dann gehen wir hoch
fangen hier an bei dem kleinen Raum der
ist nämlich so schön hier ähm was nicht
schön diese Wand ist irgendwie nicht so
gut aber dahinter könnte man theoretisch
noch ausbauen also falls wir noch zehn
Kinder kriegen das noch Platz in der
Schule
oder die kommen alle in dieses Zimmer
Gästezimmer wird und guck mal was wir
für eine schöne alte Tür ist na ich mag
die und der Boden ist auch einfach so
schön im Vergleich zu hier also hier
finde ich den Boden noch gar nicht schön
haben wir auch schon mal drunter geguckt
und wollen ihn vielleicht jetzt auch
abschleifen hier ist unser Schlafzimmer
im Moment wurden wir hier ganz
provisorisch nur auf einer Matratze wo
in zwei drei Wochen werden wir alles aus
dem Boden angeht und die Wände angeht
renoviert haben dann werden wir mit dem
ganzen Rest umziehen hier wollen wir zum
Beispiel noch die Fußleisten neu
streichen weil die so gelb sind vom
Fußboden Öl und so lauter Sachen
Kleinigkeiten und hier ist das schönste
Zimmer im ganzen Haus wir hatten viele
Diskussionen werden dieses Zimmer
einziehen darf und das wird jetzt das
Kinderzimmer
ich freue mich da schon richtig drauf
weil ich liebe das so das Kinderzimmer
schön zu machen
sehr sehr schön
wenn es fertig ist
so kleine Sterne
kommen
zukünftiges Zimmer ja ich weiß noch
nicht genau was ich hier machen will das
hat diese richtig coole Abstellkammer
ja da kann man vielleicht Bettwäsche und
so kramlagen und dann gehen wir noch mal
also hier können wir auch noch ausbauen
theoretisch was man hier machen muss ist
dämmen entweder so unterm Dach werden
uns aufbauen will oder wir dämmen
einfach den ganzen Fußboden das wäre
erstmal viel günstiger und schneller so
jetzt gehen wir mal in die Schule
jetzt ganz viele alte Geräte und
abenteuerliche Sachen drin
wir sind noch am Überlegen was hier
passieren könnte und hier ist die
coolste Mann hier kommt man hoch in den
Garten und ich frage mich ist das
ein Fledermauskasten unten ein Loch
oder ist es irgendwas anderes
hier werden wir sehen wie lange lange
Bohrmaschine
[Musik]
Gartenschuppen und Hühnerstall hier
möchte ich mein Büro reinbauen wie schön
wäre das wenn
ich hier mein Schreibtisch habe hier
meine Videos schneiden wenn irgendwas
fehlt einfach immer raus im Garten kann
und einfach wenn diese beiden Welten vom
draußen sein und vom Rechner sitzen
irgendwie verzeihen würden deswegen
würde ich den Raum gerne dämmen und
Fußboden reinmachen und das Glas ist
auch noch zum Teil Plexiglas das musst
also freut euch auf die Gartentür die
kommt da drüben verlinke ich euch das
Video zum Umzug also auch gerne rein und
ansonsten sehen wir uns im nächsten
Video wieder macht's gut tschüss